what a fantastic victory what a really
important victory for
batley and spen of hope over
division and decency over hatred
and i just want to start by saying a
massive thank you to all of you
for everything you've put in been a
great great great candidate
a great campaign and a great team and
thank you for every minute
every hour every day every week you put
in the blood you have sweated
every door that you have knocked because
that is what has brought this
about absolutely fantastic and thank you
um it took incredible courage for kim to
stand
here and to go through this campaign
incredible courage
and kim epitomizes everything i want our
labour party to be
everything i want our labour party to be
she's of her community you can't go
around badly and spend and not know
everybody knows kim however they vote
they all know kim because of what she's
put in she's of her community
she's for her community she's got
integrity she believes
in truth and honesty and in bringing
people
together and that is as i say exactly
what i want for our labour party the
values of our labour party
she will be a fantastic member of party
of parliament
for batley and spen a really fantastic
member and
i was elected into parliament on the
same day as joe cox
and we enter parliament together there
isn't a day when we all don't
miss joe but kim she would be so proud
to see you today so proud to see you um
as a member of parliament
and i know you want to have some fizz
yes i'm deserving
vision football fishing football tonight
at 5 30 this morning shots of fizz and
football
and um and some sleep i think and
that'll happen too right but
as you would say yourself kim have you
also got to crack on with it
crack down in parliament we want you
down in parliament
um and we will all be so proud i will be
so proud sitting at the dispatch box
in parliament on monday when kim is
sworn in as the member of parliament
for battley and spain
this campaign has been tough because
others have poisoned it poisoned it with
hatred
with division of finding difference of
misinformation
of lies of harassment threats and
intimidation
that that should have happened in fact
and spent of
all places is disgusting
that that should have happened to kim
of all people is unforgivable
and for all those who engaged in it and
for all those who didn't call it out
who didn't call it out they should be
utterly ashamed
of themselves this is a victory
of hope over division it is a start
labor is back labor is back
that battle that went on here between
decency and honesty and bringing people
together
and division manipulation misinformation
lies that battle isn't just in battle
and spain that is the battle of modern
politics and the labour party is in that
battle we're going to fight
all the way every inch of the way and
we're going to win
that battle we've got to fight that but
labour is back this is just the start i
want many more days like this
labour is coming home